a jury in the u.s has found a british
socialite delane maxwell guilty of
helping the late sex offender jeffrey
epstein abuse underage girls for years
after five days of deliberations the new
york jury found maxwell guilty on five
counts including recruiting and grooming
epstein's teenage victims the verdict
could see the 60-year-old spend the rest
of her life in prison
recruiting and grooming teenage victims
and trafficking a minor these are the
heavy charges of which british socialite
glenn maxwell was found guilty by the
new york jury
the road to justice has been far too
long
but today
justice has been done
no one no matter how powerful or well
connected is above the law
elaine maxwell is the daughter of
british newspaper baron robert maxwell
in court accusers showed evidence of
maxwell's close relationship to late
financier and convicted sex offender
jeffrey epstein epstein was jailed in
2019 based on charges of sex trafficking
minors but he committed suicide in
prison while awaiting trial
in the current court case of gelane
maxwell she was found to have helped
epstein systematically procure young
girls some as young as 14. the charges
against maxwell were brought forward by
four victims but many more feel they
have been served justice this is a
victory for all of the victims of miss
maxwell and epstein moreover i think
this is a victory for all young children
boys girls women and men who are victims
of abusers like this it will give them
the needed push to step forward and to
speak their truth and to hopefully get
justice like these young girls have with
respect to miss maxwell the defense says
the 60 year old is being used as a
scapegoat for other people's crimes
[Music]
we firmly believe in glenn's innocence
obviously we are very disappointed with
the verdict
we have already started working on the
appeal and we are confident that you
will be vindicated everyone be healthy
have a happy new year
maxwell now stands to spend the rest of
her life in prison if she receives the
maximum possible sentence of 65 years
so where does the case go from here
here's dw correspondent stefan simons
yeah there is a sentencing uh
date to be set and this is when the
judge comes out and announces what he's
sentenced to but you heard already the
attorney for miss maxwell saying that
they are working on the appeal so this
will definitely go into
an appeal and an appeals court will be
um then have the um
the job of sorting this out if this
appeal is is
legitimate um and
if there is a grounds actually if there
are grounds for an appeal now the
prosecution that's what many experts say
made really really sure that they're
that they give because they were
actually expecting an appeal uh no
matter what when if
ms maxwell would have been found guilty
but they made sure that this is somewhat
of an airtight um prosecution they
delivered with the testimony of those
four victims for example etc so this is
going to be a hard time for ms maxwell
in the appeals court i would think and
again 65 years in present this is the
rest of her life